la malnutrition au yémen inquiètent de
plus en plus l'unicef selon un rapport
du fonds des nations-unies pour
l'enfance publié aujourd'hui 2 millions
400 mille enfants pourraient se
retrouver au bord de la famine en raison
du manque de financement de l'aide
humanitaire
en cause la guerre qui touche le pays
depuis cinq ans un conflit qui oppose
notamment le pouvoir aux rebelles houthi
et la pandémie de locaux vides 19
aggravent également à les conditions
humanitaires mais on en parle justement
avec sébastien l'ado en direct dans ce
gîte et il est député écologie
démocratie solidarité de la haute
garonne
bonjour sébastien nadeau de merci de
répondre à nos questions en direct sur
rt france le nombre d'enfants mal
nourris pourraient être deux
2 4 millions d'ici la fin de l'année à
ce que ce chiffre vous paraît réaliste
malheureusement le chiffre paraît
effectivement réaliste et il faut dire
que ça s'ajoute à des conditions
sanitaires qui sont absolument
déplorable pas seulement lié au cours
d'un virus mais vous savez il ya une
épidémie de choléra en plus qui touche
particulièrement les enfants mais aussi
les adultes et donc on est dans une
situation d'un conflit qui n'a que trop
duré sur lequel la crise du coronavirus
vient de prendre alors que la situation
est déplorable de toutes parts on parle
de 80 enfants qui meurent chaque jour à
cause de la guerre comment remédier à
cette catastrophe l'unicef demande une
aide financière de près de 2 411
millions d'euros pour le moment seuls 39
% de cette somme ont été récoltés
comment trouver et 61 % restants alors
c'est la grande question d'abord il ya
des promesses de dons des années
précédentes qui n'ont pas été honorées
c'est à dire que on avait promis
plusieurs milliards un certain nombre de
pays est en réalité n'est pas revenue
pour aide humanitaire que environ 30 %
donc déjà ce serait bien que quand on
prend un engagement les pays qui font
partie des donateurs et qui pour
certains se donnent bonne conscience en
donnant de l'argent ici mais en
soufflant sur les braises du conflit par
ailleurs eh bien il se trouve que déjà
il ne donne pas l'argent sur lequel ils
se sont engagés avec un sens à cannes il
écoute et je crois que c'est assez
simple à comprendre
l'arabie saoudite les émirats arabes
unis qui ont quand même un problème de
conscience extrêmement fort à l'heure
actuelle de par leurs responsabilités
alors bien sûr il ya des opposants
houthistes qui qui perpétue également
des crimes de guerre sur le terrain il
ya des groupes dessus de séparatistes au
yémen on a une situation d'un pays qui
est au bord de l'explosion
et concernant l'aide humanitaire on voit
que d'une part les protagonistes ne
donne pas tout l'argent qu'ils ont
connue et d'autre part les membres du
conseil de sécurité n'assume pas du tout
leur rôle de gardiens de la paix et de
la sécurité puisque bien au contraire
compte tenu du marché de l'armement
extrêmement fort dans la région
préfèrent fermer les yeux sur le
désastre humanitaire que mettre à bas un
certain nombre de contrats mise en
justement à vous parler de l'armement
souviens il y as en or il ya un an il y
avait le fameux cargo le baril à young
boys qui devait transporter des armes
a priori française à destination de
l'arabie saoudite qui pouvait être
utilisé selon certains à destination
contre la population civile y est bénite
finalement ce bateau n'avait pas à côté
du côté du havre après l'intervention de
nombreuses ong
comment paris peut-il intervenir dans ce
conflit et yéménite est ce que ça a
proximité actuelle avec l'arabie
saoudite ou les emirats arabes unis qui
sont à la tête d'une coalition anti
l'outil est ce que c'est un obstacle à
l'action de paris même humanitaire
écoutez le mois de juin voit la
présidence de la france au conseil de
sécurité des nations unies il y a eu une
réunion il ya deux jours spécifiquement
sur la situation au yémen de cette
réunion
d'une part les propos sur la situation
humanitaire c'est de dire qu'on s'en
inquiète
mais on reste dans le dans le verbal le
discours
et puis d'autre part il ya un véritable
électrochoc
maintenant que les nations unies doivent
mener en direction du yémen
il n'est pas possible de continuer
politiquement à dire on va trouver une
solution il faut poursuivre le dialogue
et ses accès
on est arrivé à un point de non retour
puisqu'il ya ces enfants qui meurent
mais par quantité chaque jour
alors les nations unies ont un petit peu
perdu la raison ces derniers temps mais
de là à dire que toutes les nations de
la communauté internationale ont perdu
leur coeur c'est vrai que c'est une
inquiétude
la france a un rôle majeur puisqu'elle
est présente et qu'elle préside le
conseil de sécurité j'estime que la
france devrait se servir de cette
position pour agir fermement dans cette
situation elle tient à le faire selon
vous malheureusement on avance la
dernière réunion savez les réunions du
conseil de sécurité il ya une partie
publique un peu arty à huis clos
donc moi j'ai pas de retour sur la
partie à huis clos j'espère qu'il ya eu
des choses vraiment très concrètes qui
ont été avancées parce que la résolution
du mois de février du conseil de
sécurité disait
on continue comme comme avant sauf que
ça fait cinq ans qu'on a un conflit sauf
que tout va de pire en pire
donc ne rien changer politiquement sur
la situation au yémen aujourd'hui c'est
aller vers la catastrophe qui est déjà
en cours sachant qu'il ya une deuxième
catastrophe aux portes du yémen à
travers le thé trop lié safer qui va
baky qui va faire naufrage
c'est une question de temps et il ya
quand même un million de baril baril de
pétrole brut à bord ce qui signifie
qu'on va vers la plus grande catastrophe
écologique qu'on n'a jamais connu du
point de vue des échouages de bateaux
donc vraiment on concentre toutes les
problématiques au yémen est emballé issa
ont une réunion très rapide en se disant
que le temps va faire son histoire non
il ya une vraie réaction forte a mené la
france est en position pour le faire
elle attend beaucoup trop elle est
beaucoup trop attentiste dans un moment
où on a tant qu'aide et figure sur la
scène internationale qui montrent leur
volonté d'améliorer les choses et donc
la france a vraiment un rôle majeur en
ce moment à jouer
malheureusement je ne sais pas si si on
va vraiment le jouer merci sébastien
dano d'avoir répondu à la question je
rappelle que vous êtes un député
écologie démocratie solidarité de haute
garonne
merci